what's the first thing you should do
when your code throws an error obviously
you should change nothing and try to run
it again a few times if that doesn't
work you're gonna need a computer
science degree the awesome thing about
software engineering is that you can
learn to code and get a high paying job
while literally having no idea how
anything actually works it all just
feels like magic like a pilot driving a
giant metal tube in the sky while
knowing nothing about aerodynamics
[Music]
welcome to computer science 101 in
today's video you'll learn the science
behind the garbage code you've been
writing by learning 101 different
computer science terms and concepts this
is a computer it's just a piece of tape
that holds ones and zeros along with a
device that can read and write to it
it's called a turing machine and in
theory it can compute anything like the
graphics in this video or the algorithm
that recommended that you watch it at
the core of modern computers we have the
central processing unit if we crack it
open we find a piece of silicon that
contains billions of tiny transistors
which are like microscopic on off
switches the value at one of these
switches is called a bit and is the
smallest piece of information a computer
can use however one bit by itself is not
very useful so they come in a package of
eight called a byte one byte can
represent 256 different values like all
the characters that you type on your
keyboard in fact when you type into your
keyboard the character produced is
actually mapped to a binary value in a
character encoding like ascii or utf-8
binary is just a system for counting
like the base 10 system you normally use
when counting on your fingers but it
only has two characters one and zero
humans have a hard time reading binary
so most often it's represented in a
hexadecimal base 16 format where ten
numbers and six letters can represent a
four bit group called a nibble as a
developer when you write code in a
programming language it will eventually
be converted into machine code which is
a binary format that can be decoded and
executed by the cpu what it doesn't do
though is store data for your
applications for that computers have
random access memory or ram it's like a
neighborhood and inside of every house
lives a byte every location has a memory
address which the cpu can read and write
to you can think of the cpu and ram as
the brain of the computer but in order
for a computer to be useful it needs to
handle input and output an input device
might be the keyboard and mouse while an
output device might be your monitor
luckily most developers don't need to
worry about how this hardware fits
together because we have operating
system kernels like linux mac and
windows that control all hardware
resources via device drivers now to
start hacking on the operating system
your first entry point is the shell
which is a program that exposes the
operating system to the end user it's
called a shell because it wraps the
kernel it takes a line of text as input
and produces an output this is called a
command line interface not only can it
connect to your own computer but with
the secure shell protocol it can also
connect to remote computers over a
network now that you have access to the
mainframe it's time to pick a
programming language which is a tool
that uses the abstraction principle to
make computers practical to work with
for humans by simplifying different
systems layer by layer some languages
like python are interpreted that means
there's a program called an interpreter
that will execute each line of code one
by one other languages like c plus are
compiled they use a compiler to convert
the entire program into machine code in
advance before the cpu attempts to
execute it this results in an executable
file that can be run by the operating
system without any extra dependencies
now every programming language has a
variety of built-in data types to
represent the data we're working with in
our code instead of bytes we work with
more human-friendly things like
characters and numbers now the most
fundamental way to use data in your
application is to declare a variable
this attaches a name to a data point
allowing you to reuse it somewhere else
in your code python is a dynamically
typed language which means we don't need
to tell the program exactly which data
type is assigned to a variable it just
figures it out automatically however
other languages like c are statically
typed and that means you need to specify
the data type of a variable in your code
when you define a variable its value is
stored somewhere in memory on the
hardware and you may need to allocate
and free up memory throughout the
program a pointer is a variable whose
value is the memory address of another
variable which can be used for low-level
memory control many languages don't want
to deal with low-level memory management
and instead implement a garbage
collector which automatically allocates
and de-allocates memory when an object
is no longer referenced in the program
[Music]
now the data types available are
different in every programming language
but typically you'll find int to
represent whole numbers which may or may
not be signed or unsigned to represent
negative numbers as well when numbers
require a decimal point they typically
use the floating point type it's called
a float because there's only enough
memory to represent a certain range of
numbers at a certain precision and is
basically a form of scientific notation
to make computers faster if you need
more range or precision many languages
also have a double that doubles the
amount of memory used for the number now
when it comes to characters you'll
typically find the char data type to
represent a single character or more
commonly a string to represent multiple
characters together ultimately these
characters get stored in a memory
address somewhere but they need to be
stored in a certain order when the order
starts with the most significant byte
and the smallest memory address it's
called big endian or vice versa if the
least significant byte is stored in the
smallest address it's called little
endian when it comes to practical
software engineering one of the most
fundamental things we do is organize
data into data structures the most
useful data structure is probably the
array or list just like a shopping list
it organizes multiple data points in
order however it also maintains an index
of integers that starts at zero and goes
up for every new item in the list that
can be useful but you don't actually
need an index to create a list of items
another option is a linked list where
each item has a pointer to the next item
in front of it another option is a stack
that follows the last in first out
principle it's like stacking a set of
plates then when you want to access the
data you pop the last one off the top
the inverse option is a queue which is
first in first out just like when you
get into the red line the first person
there is the first one to be fed now
another extremely useful data structure
is the hash which might also be called a
map or dictionary it's like an array but
instead of an index of integers you
define the keys that point to each
individual item giving you a collection
of key value pairs in many cases though
it's not efficient to organize data in a
linear way to address that problem we
have trees which organize nodes together
in a hierarchy that can often be
traversed more quickly this can
sometimes be too rigid of a data
structure though so instead a graph can
be created to connect multiple nodes
together in a virtually unlimited number
of ways a graph has a node for the data
and an edge for the relationship between
the data points data structures are
essential but they don't do anything by
themselves to do something useful you'll
need to code up an algorithm which is
just code that solves a problem i took
the initiative in
creating the internet in our code we
have several mechanisms for implementing
algorithms the most fundamental of which
is a function which is a block of code
that takes an input then does something
and returns an output like a variable a
function has a name and it can be called
from other parts of your code with
different input parameters called
arguments one thing you might do in the
function body is compare one value to
another every language has a variety of
built-in operators like equality greater
than and less than that you can use to
compare two values if a is greater than
b then it forms a value of true but if b
is greater than a then the value is
false true false is what's known as a
boolean data type and whenever your code
produces a value like this it's known as
an expression but not all code will
produce a value sometimes your code will
simply do something which is known as a
statement a good example is the if
statement which handles conditional
logic for example if the condition is
true it will execute this code otherwise
it will short circuit and run the code
inside of the else block another very
common type of statement is a loop a
while loop will run this block of code
over and over again until the condition
in the parentheses becomes false that
can be useful but more often than not
you'll want to loop over an iterable
data type like an array most languages
have a for loop that can run some code
for every object in the array or
iterable data structure now in some
cases a function may not have an output
which is generally called a void
function an interesting thing about
functions is that they can call
themselves when a function calls itself
it's called recursion because when done
like this by default it will recurse
forever creating an infinite loop that
happens because when you call a function
the programming language will put it
into memory on what's known as the call
stack which is a short-term chunk of
memory for executing your code when a
function keeps calling itself the
language will keep pushing frames onto
the call stack until you get a stack
overflow error to avoid this your
algorithm needs a base condition so it
knows when to terminate the loop now
when you write an algorithm you'll need
to determine if it's any good and the
system for doing that is called big-o
notation it's a standard format for
approximating the performance of an
algorithm at scale it may reference time
complexity which is how fast your
algorithm will run and space complexity
which deals with how much memory is
required to run it developers have many
different algorithm types at their
disposal the most crude option is brute
force where you might loop over every
possible combination to hack somebody's
credit card pin a more sophisticated
approach might be divide and conquer
like binary search where you cut the
problem in half multiple times until you
find what you're looking for another
option is dynamic programming algorithms
where a problem is broken down into
multiple smaller sub-problems and the
result of each computation is stored for
later use using a technique called
memoization that means if a function has
already been called it will use the
existing value instead of recomputing it
again from scratch then we have greedy
algorithms that will make the choice
that is most beneficial in the short
term without considering the problem as
a whole one example of this is
dijkstra's shortest path algorithm on
the flip side we have backtracking
algorithms which take a more incremental
approach by looking at all the possible
options like a rat and a maze exploring
all the different potential paths now
when it comes to implementing your code
there are always multiple ways to get
the job done one programming paradigm is
declarative where your code describes
what the program does and the outcome
but doesn't care about things like
control flow this style of programming
is often associated with functional
languages like haskell the other
paradigm is imperative programming where
your code uses statements like if and
while providing explicit instructions
about how to produce an outcome it's
associated with procedural languages
like c today most general purpose
languages like python javascript kotlin
swift and so on are multi-paradigm which
means they support all these options at
the same time in addition to
object-oriented programming the idea
behind oop is that you use classes to
write a blueprint for the data or
objects in your code a class can
encapsulate variables which are commonly
called properties as well as functions
which are usually called methods in this
context it's a common way to organize
and reuse code because classes can share
behaviors between each other through
inheritance where a subclass can extend
and override the behaviors of the parent
class and it opens the door to all kinds
of other ideas called design patterns
now a class by itself doesn't actually
do anything instead it's used to
instantiate objects which are actual
chunks of data that live in your
computer's memory often you'll want to
reference the same object over and over
again in your code when data is
long-lived it can't go in the call stack
instead most languages have a separate
area of memory called the heap which
unlike the call stack can grow and
shrink based on how your application is
used it also allows you to pass objects
by reference which means you can use the
same object in multiple variables
without increasing the memory footprint
because it always points to the same
chunk of memory in the heap now what's
interesting is that if we go back to the
cpu that we talked about in the
beginning you'll notice that it contains
multiple threads a thread takes the
physical cpu core and breaks it into
virtual cores that allow it to run code
simultaneously there are some
programming languages that support
parallelism where you can write code
that literally executes on two different
threads at the same time however many
languages out there are only single
threaded but that doesn't mean they
can't do two things at the same time
instead they implement concurrency
models like an event loop or co-routines
that can pause or delay the normal
execution of code to handle multiple
jobs on a single thread at the same time
now in modern computing we're rarely
working with the bare metal cpu and ram
instead we work in the cloud with a
virtual machine which is just a piece of
software that simulates hardware that
allows us to take really big computers
and split them up into a bunch of
smaller virtual computers these machines
are the backbone of the internet and are
connected via the internet protocol each
machine has a unique ip address to
identify it on the network that ip
address is usually alias to a url that
is registered in a global database
called the domain name service now to
establish a connection the two computers
will perform a tcp handshake which will
allow them to exchange messages called
packets on top of that there's usually a
security layer like ssl to encrypt and
decrypt the messages over the network
now the two computers can securely share
data with the hypertext transfer
protocol the client may request a web
page then the server will respond with
some html modern servers provide a
standardized way for a client to request
data which is called an application
programming interface or api the most
common architecture is rest where urls
are mapped to different data entities
available on the server and that brings
us to our final topic mother effin
printers you're gonna need to learn how
these things work inside and out because
every time you go to grandma's house
she's going to ask you to fix it which
shouldn't be a problem for a computer
scientist like you thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one